[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel on vient de vivre un très
beau début d'émission ce lundi en direct
au débat il vous ce manque et nous aussi
rassurez vous ils sont bien sûr de
retour donc les génies du paf y sont là
alors autant en termes de foot ça a été
compliqué ce week-end pour les
marseillais on en repart à tout à
l'heure avec le psg om autant en termes
de téléralité les marseillais restent
les champions et de très loin
alors ils n'osent pas le dire mais je
sais que ça fait plusieurs jours qu'eric
naulleau se demande mais quand est-ce
calix va rejoindre les marseillais
d'innover alix est arrivée elle est
arrivée à l'x regard des photos
normalement voilà il ya une valeur les
avantages par rapport aux autres c'est
canix elle est beaucoup plus calme
elle est beaucoup plus
et fléchit alix elle est beaucoup plus
apaisé tout le reste du casting est tout
de suite sa présence a permis de faire
renaître un souffle de zénitude passer
de regarder
franchement là vous êtes sur la chaîne
zen ferrat vous êtes tranquille
installez-vous 3d qui ont fait tomber
sur les nerfs l'as de pique t'arrive
était sur les nerfs choix sont les
maires au fait c'est la cnam il a fait
chaud journées l'aja s'installe dans la
mer à me poser nettoyage ils assurent
les jeunes de discuter l'itc morinière
cette année je vous demande de vous
arrêter
sinon c'est un des coups de pression de
langue de mozart et que tu relizane
[Musique]
demande de vous arrêter ouais ouais non
mais voilà c'est pour ça que c'est un
vous adorer ça oui j'aime bien mais
c'est le seul travers maintenant
démission c'est trop flagrant que quand
ils arriveront alors qu'on hurle la
seule consigne qu'ils ont ces gens pour
qu'ils rentrent dedans de tout le monde
et donc ils se retrouveront en train de
se chamailler tout en elle ces trucs un
peu gros mais ils sont comme ça
naturellement il suffit de pousser un
peu vous avez en même temps vous avez
une fois sur les marseillais vous non
mais il ya ça tout le monde par le
marseillais s'en verrait tout le monde
chez l'orthophoniste mois pour parler ce
que ça vous intéresse d'avoir des
nouvelles de julien guerrier je viens
guirado
oui il est là voilà j'ai eu à dire ado
alors c'est le beau gosse des
marseillais s'est faufilé discrètement
dans le lit d'une demoiselle pour lui
parler à coeur ouvert
il en avait marre le problème c'est que
visiblement la fille qui est sous la
couette
elle a juste envie de dormir donc
c'était pas le voilà il n'était pas sur
le bon bail j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter
franchement c'est le vent de l'année
j'ai pu me rendre et parler dont je dois
être discret pourquoi tu veux casser mon
couple ta gueule humiliation aux lettres
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien c'est ça dont il est lui le
genevois il est amoureux non pas du tout
matthieu delormeau dans les îles et des
étoiles dans les yeux à 6,6 ici ça
n'enlève rien à mon talent n'a
heureusement attention je vous le dirai
tout de suite alors dans les marseillais
pour relever le niveau où il y à paga
ekani alors pagaille qu'à me voilà on va
voir la photo alors ils sont au pays
hyper fier d'eux car ils connaissent
plein d'expressions vraiment eux ils sur
les expressions ils sont incollables
sauf qu'ils veulent les caser tout en
même temps et là forcément c'est pas bon
c'est à dire qu'il faut les mettre à
bonne escient regarde c'est pas normal
que le reste du monde nous domine au
niveau des points là il va falloir se
relever un peu la tête de l'eau
le chili se fout clairement de moi c'est
l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité à
l'acupuncture la cerise et le truc sur
la garonne
adieu les connards mende est morte à big
bag
la démo que nadine bebek autant qu'on
est dans les marseillais sont pourvus
pour vous remonterez cette pépite vous
lisez semaine dernière w9 a demandé aux
candidats des marseillais de jouer la
carte de la sobriété
vous le savez notamment sur les tenues
est la première à avoir répondu
favorablement à cette demande
c'est manon elle s'habille y perd son
père un père sauf
et si vous n'avez pas vu écoutez bien la
dernière phrase de manon regarder sait
trop pourquoi ne s'est pas trop vu des
annonces est bon je vous conte
extraverti qu'avant points
à l'instar de jean
c'est beaucoup moins extraverti
karoutchi a perdu 2,2 à jouer à gâtés
dans les marseillais et le reste du
monde en fait ils leur donnent ce qu'ils
appellent des jobs à faire et là il me
semble que c'était un job un peu dedans
ce strip teaseuse près d'où la tenue un
peu olé olé là il ya plus de strip tease
et roula dachti ce qu'est ce que tu
enlèves quant à sa baby naït mazi nguyen
à la prince tri non plus à landen de
grand-mère focale mains deviennent une
grand mère comme ça toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est magique c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que c'est pas très sexy voilà moi moi
c'est pas ma came la meuf qui a le truc
jusqu'aux halles c'est l'éclair à la
beyoncé j'aime pas du tout à une culotte
comme ça moi je loge au volant ça sera
un dossier de free alors oui ça revient
à l'épaule et au tsar bien ce qu'est ce
que vous aimez alors avec le temps je
joue bien ça fait quinze ans que j'ai
pas bu il a pas de culotte à cet accord
devrait pas arrêter c'est bon je suis
comme voltaire l'avantagé avec castaldi
c'est que même quand elle porte sa pour
les que c'est idiot string une petite
info sur la culotte sur le string a vécu
le mal au coeur
non j'ai pas de dons ou qu'ils restaient
disparus si la culotte fondu à 8/9 on
mettait ça pour rester pudique tout en
permettant la fondue pour ta fiche reste
habillé tout en paix favorite moi j'ai
vendu une cup 14000 euros
ah ouais enfin shakespeare pour les
tribunaux vous savez et là c'était le
string et la culotte de joséphine baker
alors c'est la soeur de maurice des
champs elysées joséphine baker une
immense chanteuse
voilà black g2 j'ai deux amours pour cet
immense titan 1930 et en 1826 elle est
encore inconnue elle est apparue sur
scène nu les seins nus avec un slip avec
les bananes planète c'était du tissu
brillant
on a retrouvé ce string parce qu'un type
l'avait gala offert un milliardaire le
type est mort on s'est débarrassé
séparés de ceux ci et on l'a récupéré
il était dans un état à 1926 le slip un
don qui ont été candidats et
oui ben abid hammadou 14 14 700 euros
hors frais c'est quoi les frais de port
ce avec une vente aux enchères il ya 25%
pour le client loyer et 20% pour
l'acheteur d'accord voilà comment ça se
passe et donc ça coûte quand même des
ententes 18001 elle est dans le musée là
bas de joséphine baker aux milandes
savez dans le sud ouest c'est moi c'est
eux qui l'ont acheté
mais c'est bon mais c'était aussi une
immense résistante est aussi le club
rennais tient la ville
mais c'est une grande résistante elle
jamais non pas les culottes le pont oui
bah oui une jeune femme noire qui
s'exhibe avec une ceinture de bananes
ont préparé les seins nus pour la sq ont
arrêté un véritable événement sur lequel
d'ailleurs la pâte n'espère pas trop
dieu